good good how are you
uh this guy done working out and just
freaking practiced in my japanese so
it's quite fine how's your japanese
kenichiwa konichiwa
wow
my name is yes
that's really good dang okay japanese is
hard i think it's hard no it's easy for
me at least for at least for me like i
said santa isn't a problem i tell people
it's understanding the kanji in the
hiragana kind of down yeah now now when
you speak in a full sentence that's uh
but you can
figure it out
yeah yeah that was easy
says you i think it's hard well yeah it
says to me i guess
i mean it doesn't come easy for
everybody i have to understand that so
that's why i don't flaunt it or quoted
i'm just like i guess they're just easy
for me i don't know yeah i love japanese
i just said
yeah
yeah pearl does too don't you love
japanese
yeah she laughs
when i was a kid she's laughing
no no because torsion knows the back
story i know about the kimono i had a
very weird phase um
i don't like to talk about it um anyways
moving on
every every child is beautiful
yeah every girl wants to experience that
one time so i can't deny it yeah that's
yeah that's what it was one time hahaha
okay moving on
okay um you want you call in to be
smashed or passed you be either
okay i'm just here
okay how tall are you
i am six zero
you're five foot
i like short guys
say that again one more time i like more
than the size of jockeys you know she's
only five one she doesn't like them too
tall
i like them smarter than me
that make a lot of money
you like him shorter than you okay okay
like the horse
no no i know i know what you mean but
don't worry i'll answer that as soon as
i'm getting asking problems questions
and i'm going to get to that in a second
because she stumbled upon an interesting
thing for me to talk about but but um
what i do in my spirit not in my spare
time but what i do is job i work two
jobs where i do delivery and then i do
pressure washing and i make like at
least 30k at least
yeah and it's a lot of it's a lot of
work while trying to do youtube i put
out videos too but oh no like i said i
keep myself busy a lot
how old are you
i am three
you're one
i'm thirty yeah and i don't look at you
oh i was like you i thought you were
going to be like 22 or 23.
yeah i don't look at i know i don't i
got some good genes
black people they always look [ __ ]
younger
blessed
they do
i used to be a maker
not all of us but i haven't met one and
i live in chicago y'all always look
young
baby faces blessed seriously yeah that's
very true
i'm always i haven't met one that i was
like she aged poorly not one or him
no the i i do know some people but it's
only because they're overweight i i
can't i can think of a couple but it's
only because they're overweight
maybe wait i could see that actually
um
maybe
i guess it depends where you've uh yeah
i said i guess it depends on where
you're at
because i know everybody in certain
places they look a lot more different
than as opposed if you were like in
california as opposed to miami
yeah
i live in chicago and
oh how did this person it's cold
that's called this person this person
took my profile picture in my username
i'm so confused
wait be careful with that what are you
talking about
and the chat
lemonade big cut it out
you can do me but don't do her
it's
it's just um
crazy
i'm assuming it's lemonade i always just
assume
eliminated
um
let's see i'm trying to think of any
other questions so you're six foot you
have a good job
i would do smash
somebody just like yeah
too tall
i'm just kidding
are you actually waiting
the question is are you actually six
foot or do you just say yeah go to a
door
[Laughter]
he grunts
can't see him oh look well you can't
actually steamboat on i hold on let's
see if you guys actually see him want to
stand up
did you actually see how tall that's so
funny
do you ever go on lives
okay
he looks tall
that's actually funny i've never
actually had to stand behind my freaking
door before but
yeah oh he's us
make him do whatever
we have the same backdrop oh nice yeah
oh hold on i got like freaking like blue
lights and freaking things up in here so
so yeah people can see my art
oh you draw
um i do graphic design here and there
i've um
worked on any big projects for like two
months nice
well i'm keeping myself busy guys i
don't have time to do anything people
people are trying to get me to do
something guys i need i need like maybe
like a week off i can
do a project for you or something
because i'm just too busy your friends
just try to use you is that what i'm
hearing no no no they don't try to use
me there's a difference i use them well
they try
but they don't
no
no no because i'm just more uh able to
get the job done and probably do it the
way that they want they want it done
yeah and if not then i told him like
listen up chris if i'm unavailable help
my brother chris you can do it he's got
more time tonight
i think he
does i don't know i reposted his stuff
and i tagged rolo and brolo shared it
because it was insane umbrella always
shares my stuff
shout out i need to i need to get like
you my boy rolo shared one of my videos
and it got so many views i was like yeah
not all heroes wear capes but dude this
artist was he does like the what do you
call it cartoon whoa i can't even think
anime anime
yeah and it was insane i wanna see if i
can find it i was like dude
i love graphic design and artists and
stuff
trust me that's where the money is at i
tell people especially if you're artists
you're more likely want to get married
to a female artist
at least at least if you've been in the
field
because i've only run into like a
handful of um
female artists that actually did
portraits similar to me
and i've dated like one or two of them
and they were pretty much and they were
really artistic
i think youtubers would be compatible
with art artists
but that might be the opportunistic side
of me
i mean
like with all of you
i mean i make my own stuff well i think
it's because youtubers tend to be like
high energy yeah
yeah and like we're talkers that's why i
think they go well together but i'm
gonna i'm gonna go yeah you need a
profile probably for that like you know
to posterize yourself and you know just
merchandise yourself yeah like i need a
kanye west
you know
okay
i'm good now okay
thanks thanks for calling in
you're welcome girl sounds so rude when
she hangs up it's funny though no
because i'll try to like just leave you
just hang up on them